squeeze aujourd'hui se trouve sur john
nack metz 2 voilà on avait testé ce jeu
là quelques mots il ya quelques années
voire même quelques siècles je vais trop
loin dans cette [ __ ] de blague
on veut montrer que ce bruit on est
chaud on est chaud aujourd'hui on est
d'humeur à jouer un jeu d'horreur à
n'est ce pas bien sûr qu'on est d'humeur
oui là où je suis
ceci tu travailles question jeune
inconnu commence par te présenter s'il
vous plaît et qu'est ce que je fais ici
encore une bonne question alors qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire
oh [ __ ] jours à toi j'aime ce que je
fais je sais pas qu'un lion rugit de
succès n'est connu que les tirs on y
perd agressif
une telle est glauque à le coût de la
tva c'est la facilité un vacances et par
lui et toutes les lumières possible de
cette pièce quand même de cet immeuble
voire même de cette ville entière je
peux m'appuyer sur leur poule pour
bloquer le salut non à sa part coup de
feu tiré la chasse d'eau à l aise aux
mille sons d'ambiance super bass qui
fait qu'on va y avoir un petit son
screamer ou coilbault où ça va nous
péter la gueule
bonjour je suis innocent et très gentil
annick l eau
comment ça peut bouger tout seul me suis
prêtée à je ne peux pas entrer ici très
bien et on va trouver une clé pour que
tu puisse rentrer ok j'ai compris la
chambre 3,6 et fermé bondi toi je veux
aller au bout du couloir [ __ ] c'est un
public à la fin tout est fermé bon
ascenseur sauve moi d'ici anneaux a
nommé c'est quoi ça sert mais cette
chute qui a accroché une plaque quoi ou
attraction pressé tous parc light
attaquant ok ils me donnent le briquet
mais il ya plus de gaz y a que la partie
l'étincelle voilà la partie nulle
la partie qui te quitte abîme le pouce
en plus sa force 2 a alors vous ça nous
mène trouver l'artefact échappez vous
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas un menteur chien
heureusement non mais c'est ça un
scandale quoi pourquoi quelqu'un a
abandonné ses vêtements ici c'est vrai
ça pourquoi
soit c'est peut-être les vêtements d'un
cadavre d'un jeune cadavres alors y
aurait-il une bougie
pressés tout du scandal
no more things like dat bi tché bi tché
bi tché
j'avais oublié ces [ __ ] de squelettes
[ __ ] au pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi à quel moment c'est toi dernier
c'est sa [ __ ] d'arriver au quai encore
des fringues abandonné la bougie c'était
inséparables nature des petites
étincelles pop là qu'est ce qui se passe
bah oui c'est notre style
alors jeunes car tu serais tu me dire ou
es ce [ __ ] d'artefacts ce serait
vraiment génial apparemment je pars là
bas au squelette jetons où il était là
qu'on est rentré bien sûr que nos
missions incrusté du coup ils étaient là
fait voilà ya ce mec qui te parle dans
les oreilles mais c'est comme le 1 mais
en payant aux j'ai quitté le jeu je suis
couvert de honte et de transpiration ça
ne protégera pas faut pas être devin
pour savoir quel coffre de vie te
protègera pas bordel de merde et là
dedans excuse toi toi toi tu as fuck ou
tel un stick man ainsi que one comme ça
aux instits man est un petit coin derby
qui fait trembler le sol quand même à un
site très énervé je fais des des
étincelles ok ça peut faire extrêmement
mal si on met le briquet vraiment un
millimètre de l'oeil ok alors fait pas
les malins
qu'est ce qu'on a ici des petits os une
bougie pourquoi pleures tels qu' elle
elle ressemble à quelqu'un que je
connais ouais ouais ouais bah t'as un
dangereux psychopathe mon gars qui a mis
ça l'a eu mais tu vas pas dire ça dit tu
vois un objet quoi ça suffit oh mon dieu
qui a mis ça là ça ne me protège rappaz
a en fait ok je le jouais qu'à ramasser
un objet pour me protéger mais me dit ça
ne protégera pas et qu'est ce qui te
protégera bordel pas sûrement pas des
portraits de femmes que tu connais ça je
te le dis à quoi cela at il servi ça a
été utilisé pour boire du chat donc là
il voit juste une coupe de champagne à
ce petit l'utiliser pour boire du sang
et sequana qui fait de la trompette
l'ump-rpr [ __ ] arrêté aussi les
bêtises d'orchestre et rdi l'arrêter il
s'est fait son petit fils a été donc je
rappelle qu'on doit trouver un artefact
donc pas un squelette ou un portrait de
femme
arrêtez arrêtez harry jackson depuis
quelques temps je suis beaucoup plus
loin sensible aux scream heure là tout
ce genre de conneries [ __ ] j'ai passé
l'âge ok donc ça ça va nous tuer c'est
sûrement pas un morceau d'aluminium avec
des résidus de
de cassoulet de la veille ou encore une
porte lame oh mon dieu c'est est utilisé
pour boire du champagne allait hausser
les taxes cette boutade cette petite
boutade si vous n'avez pas trop d'humour
jeunes squelette à le seul à se déplacer
ou à l'école a pris en flagrant délit
qui venait comme ça sur la pointe des
pieds à saloperies on t'a pris en
flagrant délit un homme peut pas fermer
cette [ __ ] voilà bientôt voir que
c'est bien par là sinon je suis refermé
comme une merde je ne vois rien à
l'intérieur à [ __ ] et pas une petite
au self défense ok mais pas dans le dans
la tacc uniquement dans le le geste
vulgaire aux ascenseurs mais dites donc
vous ne pouvez pas quitter son art fact
oh non c'est une blague
je déteste quand tu arrives à la salle
finale et qu'on te dit emma non non je
vois 203 que j'ai pas visité comment on
fait faudrait qu on la tire là dedans il
est là mon conte et à bientôt
allez hop soul ans ferme alors vous
faire garde qu'on reviendra ne pas aller
tout droit fait puisque justin la porte
voilà vous êtes mon même au hockey il ya
un doute que des [ __ ] de coupe de
champagne dans ses coffres peut pas y
avoir une bonne grosse lampe torche avec
120 piles aa même un jeu aaa ayant
battlefield avec une console aa aussi
alors
l'artefact ça va ça vient au jeu lui ça
ressemble à une clé de la chambre
d'hôtel où se trouve la sortie
maintenant on est d'accord ça si je
passe à l'habitude et j'ai envie j'ai
envie de vous demander
voilà oui oui je pense tu meurs mais je
suis pas sûr non t'inquiète c'est un
passage secret à skip assis à skip c'est
un passage secret alors il n'y a qu'un
moyen de savoir messieurs dames
mon dieu mais [ __ ] je vous demander à
chaque fois je suis bloqué devant être
bordel de merde s'il vous plaît un
artefact ou une sortie l'un des deux
voilà on ça vient la sortie trop bon
pirelli hockey ou pires que la sortie
c'est pas c'est pas par l'ascenseur
là-bas le gros trépas route d'où l'on
vient où c'est beau ça c'est nouveau
alors ça bien j'adore cette expression
autres c'est vraiment les grincheux qui
disent ah s'il vous plaît monsieur
l'ascenseur donc la sortie à ce que
l'équipe nsydia marché tout langage
d'opium
1 on se comprend et venez assister à
l'incroyable spectacle tout ce qu il est
donc juste est en train de vous dire je
joue si on peut pas aller là dedans ou
c'est un piège en fait il ya quand même
le savoir n'est faso de 50 cm au bon
goût et [ __ ] à un millimètre près elle
était bonne pour nous la place est aux
aguets responsable de sa tasse m
vous allez place soit encore voilà
encore un peu au pas trop non plus au
pot je veux pas le smac c'est la sortie
d'une porte qu'elle n'avait pas vu qui
était tapi dans l'ombre tourner la roue
pourtant fuir oui c'est ça la sortie
monga finalement c'est comme ça que tu
tournes une roulade fait juste gauche
droite gauche ses parts à bonbons outre
outre ce détail à l on fait quoi on met
le coup de pinceau le réveil 16 novembre
00h03 pourquoi je suis encore là nickel
ça recommence je devrais regarder en
dehors de cette chambre
113 papin au talent fou mais n'y en pas
là de danseurs de questions même contre
un jouet dessin je ne le ferai pas bon
ok vous être mon point faible à aller on
entre dans la pièce
bah écoute si utile du m'avait pas
bloquer l'entrée avec ce [ __ ] de
ballon peut-être que je pourrai venir te
voir tu ne me dis pas qu'on doit
reprendre l'ascenseur pour retrouver une
clé pour revenir et rentrer dans une
autre chambre dans lequel on peut même
pas rentrer pure à quoi cette fois mais
qui jongle trouve l'artefact et sauve
toi godmode actimel et maintenant en
français version invincible activée
voilà je fais aussi partie des power
rangers 6 oscars est ce aux karens
oscars et de sauce caraîbes sens qu'à
waouh t'es tout donné les paroles d'une
chanson à chanter pour peut-être que
l'artefact arrive comme ça efface autres
sont de super bien dis donc
karamyan fin duos ou ya aucun problème
aux audi ton nom un petit enfant se
saouler et voit la mise en scène par
beyoncé on tient ce spectacle là je peux
passer ou pas ou penser on va le tenter
oh la technique de l'homme sans
testicules
oh mon dieu quelqu'un est fâché de
l'autre côté serait ce les wc de la map
formé au [ __ ] et d'épée mais ses
stocks
mais pourquoi ces crises à pato au mur
ce petit bourg et refaire annonce la
paix comme ça tu l'a très mal fait oui
on voit les gens c'est bien fait pardon
le micro est encore petit caleb où l on
voit les gens c'est déjà fin de cette
vidéo je sois si vous a plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude désolé d'avoir dû finir sur
cette fin voilà sur même pas le beau cri
de la fille mais sur le manche crient de
la fille
on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo encore mais le savoir
regardez vous êtes top kart monde puisse
en vente à tout gâcher câble est maître
là comme ça